cette manifestation à des gilets jaunes
dans la capitale ce samedi l'appel a été
lancé sur les réseaux sociaux les
manifestants sont attendus à bercy pour
un départ du cortège en début
d'après-midi plusieurs revendications
annoncé notamment celle de lutter contre
la précarité et on retrouve sur place
notre reporter qui rit kotlikoff bonjour
kirill alors la manifestation ne va pas
tarder à démarrer quelle est l'ambiance
sur place bien vous le voyez derrière
moi ils sont environ une centaine sur
les marches du palais omnisports paris
bercy certains sont encore installés
dans les cafés aux environs en train de
se en train de discuter cela faisait un
moment que le gilet jaune ne s'était pas
rassemblés le 15 août aujourd'hui une
période plutôt creuse mais à paris les
jets les jeunes ont quand même décidé de
faire une marche aujourd'hui cette
marche va débuter à 14h30 pour l'instant
on est à quelques quelques secondes de
quelques minutes pardon du début de
cette marche elle va emprunter la
direction de la gare de lyon en passant
par la place de la bastille pour
finalement se terminer aux alentours de
18 heures place de la nation voilà pour
l'instant tout est très câble à noter
toutefois une présence policière assez
impressionnante plusieurs dizaines de
camions de crs sont placées aux abords
de la place de paris bercy et quelques
policiers qui se sont copieusement fait
siffler en arrivant à moto tout à
l'heure mais globalement l'ambiance est
très calme et bon enfant aujourd'hui on
s'était vus d'après midi merci à tirer
une copie kof pour toutes ces
informations